If we don't have enough usable
data to solve the problem,
then we need to set up an experiment
to help us get the data we need.
An experiment in a business context is
usually referred to as an A/B test.
For example, you want to know
how replacing an old product
with a similar new product
will impact sales.
Since you don't have data for
sales of the new product, you don't have
data to do any modeling or prediction.
To determine sales of the new product,
you can set up an experiment.
You could introduce the new product
in just a few stores to help estimate
the impact on sales if you introduce
the product at all stores.
Just picking any stores for
your experiment won't work very well.
Therefore, it's important to
design your experiment so
you can use the results at other stores.
I'll go into more detail in a course
focused entirely on A/B testing.